salut en directo américa de france a 24
está con nosotros más romeros a la mar
lamentablemente siguen creciendo los
casos de hepatitis aguda en niños y
niñas alrededor de todo el mundo le
pregunto que sabemos sobre esta
enfermedad y qué está pasando con esto
si volvamos a hacer seguimiento de este
caso que ya hemos ido mencionando en
este espacio de salud la verdad es que
desgraciadamente seguimos sabiendo muy
poco por eso se está ganando ese titular
de mis labios o en los medios de
comunicación escuchemos la última
actualización de la organización mundial
de la salud de ayer
a la fecha del primero de mayo al menos
228 probables casos se han reportado a
la o ms desde 20 países distintos con
más de 50 casos bajo investigación
los casos se han registrado en cuatro de
nuestras de seis regiones de lado ms la
mayoría desde europa pero también desde
las américas el pacífico occidental y el
sudeste asiático
[Música]
repasemos estas regiones de las que
estaban hablando en la organización
mundial de la salud efectivamente europa
sigue siendo el país en más afectados
especialmente reino unido donde ha sido
pues el primer país además donde se
reportaron estos casos también vemos en
el lado asiático estamos hablando de
japón y de indonesia y pues en el
continente americano eeuu también hay
casos en investigación en canadá todavía
no ha llegado américa latina' pero los
sistemas de vigilancia en alerta y
esperemos que no llegue américa latina
pues ya sabemos que nuestros sistemas de
salud están bien débiles más después de
la pandemia y pues no queremos más
complicaciones ojalá no llegue pero que
está provocando esta enfermedad mar pues
la verdad es que es el gran misterio a
día de hoy todavía se desconoce con
certeza qué está sucediendo la hepatitis
recordemos que es la inflamación del
hígado eso puede suceder por causas
ambientales por ejemplo excesivo consumo
de alcohol de medicamentos o de drogas
pero sobre todo la principal causa de
hepatitis son 5 virus a b c d así se
conocen o hepatitis a hepatitis b lo que
pasa es que no se ha encontrado ninguno
de estos virus en estos niños infectados
además son niños todos menores de edad
sobre todo menores de 10 años se barajan
también que pueda ser causado por
factores ambientales que no se hayan
identificado pero se dice que es menos
plausible y el principal sospechoso es
otro virus se llama de no virus 41 los
virus son virus que circulan con una
cierta normalidad suelen estar detrás de
resfriados en el caso del 41 detrás de
gastritis o gastroenteritis de leves
pero nunca se había visto que causarán
estos cuadros graves de enfermedad
entonces pues lo que se dice es que
podría ser que esta infección que se ha
visto en un porcentaje alto de todos
estos niños afectados pueda haberse
sumado a algún otro factor y así haber
desarrollado una información hay alguna
relación más entre la vacuna de ccoo y
19 con estos casos pues la verdad es que
hace falta decir que rotundamente no
pero simplemente está corriendo esta voz
en algunas en redes sociales sobre todo
relacionado con la vacuna de johnson
johnson porque esta vacuna usa un
adenovirus como vector
para el 19 para usar los anticuerpos de
condicionado y despertar una respuesta
inmune sin embargo es imposible que ésta
de no virus que está muerto además se
replique en el cuerpo otra cosa es que
haya una relación con la enfermedad de
kobe 19 que algunos niños también
presentaban y esto pues puede ser que
suceda debemos estar preocupados marc
pues para empezar la preocupación es
comprensible sobre todo porque no
conocemos la causa eso añade algo de
ansiedad y tensión no porque además
mientras no sepamos la causa no sabremos
pues qué está pasando cómo prevenirla o
cómo se transmite sin embargo los
centros de control y de prevención de
enfermedades en europa lo han declarado
un evento de salud pública de
preocupación
otras claves importantes dicen que la
enfermedad es rara que poca evidencia
que no sabemos el riesgo real pero que
por el tema de que pueden resultar en
cuadros graves hay cuatro fallecidos ya
es esta preocupación que ahora mismo
tenemos más gracias por toda la
información pasamos ahora a ver nuestra
segunda invitada del día esto en el
marco de las entrevistas que hicimos en
la feria de libro